I'm on my way to meet a man who claims
to smuggle guns into the UK Sky News can
reveal the National Crime Agency has
noted an alarming increase in firearms
on our streets
and Sam is not his real name says he
uses this gun himself that he's paid by
drugs gangs to do their dirty work crime
agencies fairs there are more guns in
the hands of organized criminals than
ever before it confiscated a hundred and
four illegal firearms in 2017 18 that
rose to 168 the following year but in
the last 10 months alone they've already
seized four hundred and twenty five guns
so the quantity has quadrupled in three
years would you say there are more than
ever before it feels that there's more
than ever before and if you look at the
statistics that we've got the seizures
are on the increase yes that means we're
being more successful as obtaining them
but also it could indicate that there's
more available forensic teams have had
recent high-profile success in linking
single weapons to multiple shootings so
unused so-called clean guns are
preferred and he cooked the Chief
Constable of Merseyside Police had
predicted this rise in clean guns coming
in right seen far more newly inferred
firearms for more firearms that have
been used to the first time as opposed
to firearms that have been used time and
time again that very clearly spells us a
problem when I first met Sam a few
months ago he explained how he got his
guns in from Europe
and when I go to Belgium but we saw the
gun have too much Gandia yeah because I
be Franz I debated and all the time I go
by Gandia and someone some people did
man the jungle and some glorious company
and the driver I don't know somebody put
the gun didn't put the tracker and if
they check around on the tracker as well
and the people interviews with I kid
agree possible everything you give you
depend about the car so that said a
lorry China just even know I don't know
I go to colleton Gandhi calligrapher gun
and I have some more example I give you
five guns are sometimes posted here from
America but in parts of Europe it's
legal to own decommissioned guns that
criminals can convert back into lethal
weapons criminals can buy those firearms
perfectly legally and and they will
bring them into the UK obviously as they
reach the UK that they're either illegal
before they get here or they're readily
convertible ie they can drill them out
and make them an illegal firearm with
great ease last year this man Stephen
spires was convicted as part of a gang
trying to important ninety five guns
into the UK from Europe as with Sam's
operation the driver was seemingly
unaware of his cargo in August last year
a man was stopped in Dover with 60 guns
concealed in his car panels and this
gang sailed their guns in from France
and up the Medway in a private yacht but
the National Crime Agency was waiting it
was the largest haul of automatic
weapons seized on the UK mainland police
say they're lobbying in Europe to try
and make convertible guns illegal in the
meantime it's just a case of trying to
stop people like Sam Jason Farrell it's
guy news